it's important to know that vaccines not
only protect you but your community as
well
many diseases that vaccines prevent are
spread from person to person
when only a few people in your community
are vaccinated the risk of a disease
outbreak is high
but if most people are vaccinated it's
much less likely for a disease to spread
this is called Community or herd
immunity
herd immunity is especially important to
protect people who can't be vaccinated
this includes people with weakened
immune systems serious allergies or
other health conditions
vaccines protect you your family and
your community from diseases that can be
dangerous or even deadly